okay so we are continuing our series on
Adam the legend of blue Marvel the
greatest origin story ever told in the
history of Marvel Comics and I don't
care what anybody says if you disagree
you're wrong so here's the thing it's a
little heavy-handed but I stand by it
sorry not sorry so here's the thing what
we end up doing here is jumping back to
1962 yet again and what this does is
again it kind of picks up here at the
Pentagon with a guy named General Mason
and the big question they have here what
they what they talk about is the
aftermath of everything going on with
blue Marvel and what they come to this
realization of is that blue Marvel is
not necessarily dead right that he's
actually alive but what the what Crews
had really alluded to and what we can
really infer here and is basically
confirmed later on is that Adam Brashear
stepping down as a superhero the world
needed to know or at least at least
needed to believe that he was out of the
picture because remember when the the
world first realized really the United
States first realized that Adam Brashear
was a black eye to the blue Marvel was a
black guy that you had this big rift
that form that was rooted in fear and
desire based on that right on one hand
it was the black community saying you
have to fight on our side you're one of
us you have to join our cause on the
other side you had white Americans who
were terrified of what he might do if he
did do that and again where he had
reiterated with President Kennedy like I
am not adherent to any one race right if
a meteor is coming to crash into Earth
it's not going to crash into Earth and
only kill black people it's going to
kill everybody it's not going to only
kill white people it's gonna kill
everybody right so I am a savior or
protector of the world not any one
particular group that with the world
having believed that he was dead and out
of the picture the hope is that while it
wouldn't necessarily cure all race
relations in the states it would at the
very least quell that issue itself but
the bigger Factor here is that even
though blue Marvel had stepped down at
the request of the president the
government still didn't trust him they
didn't believe that he would somehow
turn against him now again this is all
fear it's all rooted in fear and
paranoia and so what you end up getting
is an agent that calls uh basically
Marlene Frazier in and she's relatively
new right she's just brand and new to
this whole thing and quite literally he
starts talking to her about her personal
life that she was born or at least she
comes from like Mississippi and that
kind of a thing this guy comes from New
Orleans showing a bit of Common Ground
trying to create some familiarity
between each other but what she does or
at least what he does is he asks her the
question how do you feel about colors
now one of the things that I want to
specify here and one of the things that
you notice here is she doesn't react
with some level of disgust right like my
God like why would you refer to Black
individuals that way instead it's I mean
I never really thought about it I never
really gave it a whole lot of thought
before so she's neither for or against
black Americans in general she just more
or less kind of seems neutral and the
response to this guy is saying like you
know they're different than us agent
Frazier right their cultures their value
they're not the same as us they're a
different group of people now
historically speaking that's the
justification one group uses to
marginalize another because by creating
that differentiation what it does is it
allows you to categorize them and then
you can categorize them based on the
differing factors of your culture and he
even goes as far as to say if I had my
my preference on this I wouldn't drag I
wouldn't expose you to to this whole
huge thing but at the end of the day our
personal Comforts have to go away so
where she initially perceives this as
simply just kind of a general Mission
even though she doesn't necessarily know
the specifics of it his response is we
need you to get close to Adam Brashear
right you probably know him as the blue
Marvel and when she asks how close he
says like do you have a fiance and she
says no and he's like good so ultimately
what we end up finding out is this bit
of History here is actually being told
to Adam Brashear by his wife now here's
one of the things that I also want you
to take note of is that I wouldn't go as
far as to say that his wife is like a
narcissist focusing strictly on herself
but in the exchange between the two she
never really looked at the situation as
it's unfolding in the present which is
to say all this information being dumped
to Adam Brashear from his perspective
right one of the things you're going to
constantly see as a theme when them when
they're talking is well how do you how
do you think it made me feel imagine
what I had to go through with all of
this it's never really an instance of
I'm sorry that I did this to you and I
can't imagine what you're going through
right now it's well me me right like
look look at what I'm going through that
kind of a thing and so in the end Adam
Brashear feels a massive amount of
betrayal here because what this woman
had done right what Marlene had done
she'd done her job and she did it well
she studied everything that was going on
with the black community and even black
history itself right she said he Booker
T Washington Richard Wright Ralph
Ellison Franz Fannin I think is how you
pronounce his name not really familiar
with that guy but like all these
different people right studied all these
different members of the black community
the history of the black community in
the United States going back to slavery
so on and so forth like all these things
and that when the the agency felt like
she was ready well then Adam Brashear
got a new neighbor and her car broke
down in Georgetown and you know they
kind of bumped into each other and that
sort of a thing literally engineering a
meeting point between the two what's so
interesting about this is that Marlene
from her perspective it's one thing to
study racial issues in the United States
academically it's another to live
through it to actually experience that
yourself right anybody can read about
racism in the United States but I would
go so far as to say that those
individuals who lived through the 1960s
have a much stronger grasp of what
racism was like in the 60s than anybody
who ever came after the 60s and simply
just read about it it doesn't mean that
reading about it has no value is
somebody just saying there's a whole
different ball game between experiencing
something and just reading about
something and so with Marlene she was
reading about the races and the blacks
had to endure she was reading about
systemic issues that blacks went through
in the 1960s going forward and so when
she and Adam Brashear were together she
didn't fully grasp what it was or at
least what it meant to be a black man
living in the 1960s and so when she
takes him to a restaurant right this
really really fancy restaurant there's a
sign that says whites only and it just
never really hit her before she was just
kind of like this actually happens you
know because for her she had never
actually seen it or never paid attention
to it she was just kind of living out in
the world essentially doing her thing
now as time progressed her assignment
was to be close to Adam Brashear but to
always maintain that sort of uh I guess
that barrier between the two of them to
never actually fall all in Love But as
time went on she did and the reason why
is because with all the things that he
had to endure over the course of his
life that he had somehow still managed
to find a way to work past all of it
right to still come out on top wouldn't
it be very very easy for a person to
succumb to that to be filled with so
much his anger and hatred and vitriol I
mean Lord knows I struggle with that on
a personal level I'm being honest with
you guys but the thing about this is
that as the two of them work together as
a couple she started encountering
instances where Not only was he
experiencing racism people who were
actually goading fights because in turn
it would lead to him being punished
right locked up in jail assaulted by the
cops or simply just a chance for them to
gang up and assault him but she
experienced racism through him that they
saw her as a race Trader right you're a
white woman dating a black man you've
betrayed your own race which was a very
prominent thing for those white
individuals who actually Ally themselves
with black Americans during that point
in time whether it was through romance
friendships what have you not only that
and what's really kind of ironic here
for all this Glitz and glamor and all
this talk that these guys put on none of
them really knew how close they came to
dying because at any point in time Adam
Brashear could have killed them all he
could have just executed them right
there thrown them into space right like
flown them all to the Sun and dropped
them off just left them in the vacuum of
space where they would suffocate and die
and so it's a crazy situation when you
look at it for what it is like these
guys have no clue how how close it was
they came to dying but at the end of the
day with all this information being
given to Adam Brashear despite the fact
that they shared all this time together
in his mind it was all based on a lot
now let's be honest with ourselves here
this is Adam Brashear being emotional
and rightfully so right he's basically
being told by the woman he was married
to and that he formed a life with the
entire basis behind us meeting was based
on a lie and was predicated on the idea
that the federal government didn't trust
you so even though you accepted the
president's orders of stepping down as a
superhero against your better judgment
even though you still uh you know went
on like a final mission even after
everything you've done to protect the
world they still didn't trust you and I
was the person assigned a spy on you
that's basically what he's being told
and so sure there is the whole life they
shared together but the level of
betrayal that Adam Brashear is
experiencing is something that somebody
just cannot be ignored and so ultimately
he leaves her behind and he even goes so
far as to ask her like what's your
actual name and she says my real name is
Marlene and he says I think I would have
really liked her and basically goes away
now at that point he flies to the Moon
literally ends up on the moon itself now
the way that Adam brochure is able to
breathe here is this is what's called
the Blue area of the moon now the blue
area of the moon is a section of the
Moon that was established by the cree
race during the inhuman project when
they were basically creating Inhumans on
Earth so it's a section of the Moon that
has oxygen so you can walk around freely
and a lot of people have used the blue
area of the Moon as their base of
operation right like the villain
apocalypse did it at one point in time
when he fought like the X-Men and X
Factor and the Inhumans over basically
cable when he was a little baby um the
X-Men have operated here for a temporary
period in time the Inhumans stayed here
for a little while which made sense
because nobody wanted him on Earth
because he and humans suck but the point
behind this is that a lot of people have
used this as a basis of operations
within Marvel Comics and so Adam sheer
being here is a way for him to quite
literally leave the Earth behind and in
doing that he actually comes to meet
with a watch really so Watcher comes to
meet with him and the two of them start
having a conversation because what we
find out is that in the early days of
him being a superhero he actually ends
up meeting with the Watcher or at least
the Watcher encounters him so jumping
back to 1962 when the two of them first
encounter each other is actually Adam
Brashear with a presidential medal of
freedom in hand he's so pissed off he
throws it at the moon and almost cracks
the moon in half right that's how strong
he is in terms of just throwing an
object the size of a half dollar into
the moon and so as the two of them talk
it's one of those things where Adam
Brashear makes us offhand a remark and
just being like dude I can't believe it
man even when I leave the Earth folks
are still white out here and when when
the Watcher changes his appearance to
like a black man it actually turns off
Adam Mercier he's like no like that does
not really make me feel any better but
the two of them starts talking and what
the Watcher really reveals to Adam
Brashear here is on Earth that's where
you've operated you've been here on this
world your entire life and you've
operated as a superhero on this world
your entire life but I promise you the
issues you're going through on your
world are not isolated to your world
that the nature of every being that
exists out there their heart is just
Wicked it's sick and wicked Above All
Else and so when when Adam's like what
in the world is that supposed to mean
The Watcher says so much about who we
are revolves around appearance and
pedigree what group you belong to who's
Superior and who's inferior but in the
end we each go the way of All Flesh we
go to dust and he says I know of a
people called the cree they've built
these ruins on which we stand Millennia
ago but it was the same problems blue
Skins versus pink skins Brothers versus
brothers and he says all fools all
doomed do not let that happen to this
precious world so it's more of the
Watcher illustrating this idea that it's
a result of what it means when you have
two sentient beings in the same room and
they're both they both belong to the
same race but one looks different than
the other now in the midst of all this
and what's so ironic is that Adam
Brashear in a lot of ways questions
whether or not Connor Sims was right is
Humanity Beyond worth saving is Humanity
a lost cause here is it worth getting
involved or really even trying to save
the human race itself if the human race
is just a continued representation of
Life as we know it across the cosmos
which is just predicated on just
intolerance among the various races on
any one particular world or among any
one particular Empire then maybe being a
misanthropic person is the way to go
Humanity as a whole is pointless they're
up to they're never a good thing that
kind of thing and so as a result of that
you end up having like this of course
well at least it seems like an
earthquake but the Scout that Adam
Brashear had previously defeated of
course that entire space Fleet comes to
attack the Earth and that's when The
Watcher challenges his convictions and
he says okay so let's say that you are
right Adam Brashear let's say that
Connor Sims was correct that Connor Sims
was a person who looked at the entire
racial war that was taking place in the
United States at the time and the Very
is just tragedies that have happened
over the course of humanity and it come
to the conclusion they gotta go right
the human race just sucks right humanity
is just just a really really crappy
thing that exists out there if you truly
believe that Adam Brashear let that
alien race attack the Earth and let them
obliterate the whole of humanity do
nothing to save it just let them die if
that's really what you believe let
Humanity die and ultimately the response
of Adam Brashear is no because in his
heart of hearts he doesn't actually
believe what he's saying he's just
exceedingly angry he's just really
really pissed off and he's like no I'm
not going to let the entire human race
die because while there are a lot of
really really crappy people out there
there are good people out there the
result to that is you have Adam Brashear
who of course jumps to the rescue and
ends up attacking the entirety of this
this Fleet right basically destroys the
whole thing and so that's when you have
this conversation because again we're
kind of back here in the in the in the
present a little bit you know but what
you end up having is this conversation
between these guys we're in the end the
The Watcher says you can't simply just
stay here right like you you can't just
exist here on the moon you have to step
back into the light and where where Adam
Brashear is like Auntie man's back right
like Auntie man's here I want to go back
to being a superhero but in the end I
don't know if I should the response of
The Watcher is but you have to and the
reason why is because you're the only
one who can stop anti-man it'd be
different if the Avengers could stop him
or something like that and sure I guess
they could assemble The Infinity
Gauntlet but like no one ever readily
does that because the stones want to be
together and people get drunk on the
power of the gauntlet plus it's kind of
overkill for a situation like this right
I mean it's literally like finding an
ant colony in your backyard and rolling
in with like a backhoe right I mean it's
like oh I mean I guess you could dig a
giant hole in your backyard for an ant
hill but why not just use the right tool
for the right job it's a little Overkill
to break out the Infinity Gauntlet to
kill the anti-man but unless right of
course anti-man ends up returning out in
the Sahara Desert and so with his
re-emergence what Reid Richards also
starts to realize is the anti-man kind
of phasing in and out of the world is
actually a symptom of a much larger
problem that what's going on here is
that with the anti-man showing up on
Earth what he's indirectly doing is
creating a bridge between the antimatter
universe and the positive matter
universe in effect the entirety of the
earth will be destroyed by antimatter
energy so it's really kind of Kevin
Grievous just being like okay so here's
our timetable and here's our main threat
now let's go forward with our
traditional superhero story that's
really what he's doing here with this
whole thing but where the conversation
between Reed and Stark kind of goes from
okay so anti-manage return to how in the
hell are we going to defeat this guy
right there's antimatter storms around
the world people are basically dying
there's a tap on the window of The
Shield Helicarrier where Tony Stark
resides only for him to be met with Adam
Brashear who simply says director Stark
I hear you wanted to see me with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end thank you all for
watching and I'll catch you all later
peace